ça fait 20 ans que je sais que vous
savez que nous savons que les vêtements
que nous portons sont fabriqués à
l'autre bout du monde par des personnes
exploitées sous payés parfois même
encore par des enfants on le sait au
moins depuis le scandale qui a frappé la
marque nike en 1996 lorsque le magazine
life publiait des photos d'enfants
pakistanais cousant à même le sol des
ballons pour la prestigieuse marque de
sport pour 6 cents de l'heure dans mon
métier je suis amené à rencontrer des
responsables de grandes multinationales
de l'habillement et la grande
distribution
je me souviens d'un rendez vous
particulier avec le responsable du
développement durable du groupe casino
rémy avec l'ennemi on a fini par bien se
connaître à force de fréquenter dans ce
type de rendez vous en octobre 2010 lors
de ce rendez vous au bout de notre
échange cours duquel je lui ai demandé
mais quelles mesures concrètes
son enseigne met en oeuvre pour
s'assurer des bonnes conditions sociales
de travail des ouvriers qui fabriquent
les vêtements de la marque réunion me
répond mi-agacé ni épuiser écouter nayla
ce les conditions travaillent en fait
rien parce que personnellement voilà ah
bon personne ne demande les
consommateurs s'en foutent
vous vous en foutez s'éteint
ce qui est assez rare c'est comme un cri
du coeur quand même pour rémy lui non
plus la pas envie de travailler les
enfants l'autre bout du monde
il se rend bien compte depuis nord qu'il
a aucun élément tangible à me donner sur
la façon dont l'ancien y qui l'emploie
s'intéresse à ces questions et pour moi
ce cri du coeur de vos de rémy mais ça
en appel à l'insurrection
toujours est il qu'en 2010 la grande
distribution n'a rien à faire des
conditions de travail de ceux qui
fabriquent ces vêtements parce qu'elle a
décidé que personne n'en avait rien à
faire 24 avril 2013
à dacca capitale du bangladesh leur à
naples asa à l'immeuble de huit étages
s'effondre bilan 1138 morts plus de 2000
blessés la plupart handicapés à vie
parmi les 5000 qu'il y travaillait les
images des corps au milieu des décombres
ont fait le tour de la planète et les
noms pleuvent benetton au chant c'est à
mango prime marque et une vingtaine
d'autres hélas le monde découvre ce
qu'il s'était déjà le monde c'est moi
c'est vous c'est nous ça s'appelle un
réveil
certains diront une gueule de bois on
découvre
les grandes déclarations des
multinationales ne suffisent pas on
découvre que les codes d'éthique les
chartes éthiques
les iluv la planète placardée en 4 par 3
ne suffisent pas éviter les drames
on découvre que la recherche de profit à
tout prix n'est pas compatible avec
l'intérêt général on découvre que les
ouvriers du textile ont un visage les
multinationales elle-même découvre
qu'elle faisait fabriquer une partie de
leur production c'est dans cet immeuble
délabré
on découvre que tout cela est fait au
nom de notre volonté de consommation de
prix bas en notre nom
on découvre qu'on contribue un monde
dont on ne veut pas et ce monde va se
mettre en mouvement
en quelques semaines un million de
personnes à travers le monde vont signer
une pétition qui demande à ses grandes
marques de signer un accord qui les
oblige à financer un système indépendant
d'inspection de leur usine
une pétition au contenu un peu technique
pas facile pour nos ong a expliqué
et pourtant un million de signatures cet
accord notre ong la soumettez à ces
grands groupes des mois avant
l'effondrement de l'immeuble
aucune n'avait accepté de le signer elle
nous disait que leur propre système de
vérification était déjà bien en place
absolument infaillible
cet accord h&m le signe sous la pression
un mois après l'effondrement de
l'immeuble
elles sont plus de 200 à l'avoir signée
aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce qu'un tel accident
arrive encore en 2013
vingt ans après le premier scandale qui
a ébranlé l'industrie du textile
après les premiers boycott de
consommateurs le parce qu'en 2013
on a le droit on a le droit
lorsqu'on est une multinationale
d'exploiter la main d'oeuvre à l'autre
bout du monde ou plutôt les conventions
internationales interdisent mais elles
n'ont prévu aucun système de sanctions
un peu comme si on vous interdisait à
passer au feu rouge mais que vous
n'aviez aucune amende le cas où vous le
feriez ont considéré qu on vous fait
confiance peuvent vous allez respecter
la loi
sauf que pour les citoyens on n'a pas
décidé que la confiance suffisait pour
les multinationales 6 avril 2015
deux ans après le drame après deux ans
de campagne internationale d'opinion des
dizaines d'actions dans ses boutiques
médiatisé des semaines d'action sur les
réseaux sociaux un million à nouveau de
signatures récoltées benetton accepte
d'indemniser les victimes durana plaza
ce sont deux belles victoires
ces victoires elles sont celles de
l'indignation mais pas n'importe
laquelle
l'indignation citoyenne et celles qui
poussent à l'action
ce sont de vraies victoires on peut pas
s'en satisfaire
on peut pas s'en satisfaire parce que ça
fait 20 ans qu'on le sait donc et 20 ans
que les choses ne changent pas vraiment
alors la solution idéale la plus
efficace
ce serait que l'on change nos
comportements de consommation mais force
est de constater qu'au bout de vingt ans
on n'a toujours pas vraiment fait brûler
nos modes de consommation surtout dans
l'habillement pour plusieurs raisons
d'une part on a quand même envie de
surconsommer des vêtements dont on sait
qu'on les paye bien en-deça de leur prix
réel de leur coût réel
mais c'est aussi parce que l'alternative
est mince mais pourquoi est-ce que
l'alternative est mince parce qu'un
problème de taille
l'accès à l'information
nous n'avons aujourd'hui aucune
information sur les conditions dans
lesquelles sont fabriquées les vêtements
que nous achetons en france et en europe
je propose de prendre un petit moment
pour regarder les
les étiquettes à l'intérieur de vos
vestes de vos vêtements
si vous arrivez dans le noir bon
j'imagine ne fait pas la première fois
que vous le regardez votre étiquette et
parmi les informations vous allez y lire
vous allez en trouver deux qui sont
obligatoires la composition du vêtement
et ses conditions d'entretien
les deux informations que le législateur
a considéré essentiel et conques
obligatoire et pour cause la première
protège le consommateur d'éventuels
risques pour sa santé d'allergie par
exemple est la deuxième protège la
marque
le fabricant d'éventuelles actions en
justice pour le cas où un scandale aussi
insoutenable qu'un pull qui rétrécir et
au lavage surviendrait sur cette
étiquette
le travailleur celui qui a confectionné
le vêtement est ignorée il est réduit à
un simple facteur de production un outil
ignorer cette étiquette
le lobby économique a bien fonctionné
vous commencez à voir le problème par
exemple ce soir
comment est ce que je suis habillé tu
fais un effort ici j'ai les baskets
d'une marque de commerce équitable je
sais que le travailleur a été payé
correctement décemment je connais la
transparence achats de production parce
que la marque me l'a donnée ici j'ai un
haut d'une marque qui se dit éthique je
me suis un peu renseigné aussi sur les
contrats courts et son travail ça c'est
calme un petit budget et puis là voilà
je suis comme tout le monde j'ai eu jean
que j'ai acheté pas trop cher
je n'ai aucune idée des conditions dans
lesquelles il a été fabriqué mais je me
doute vu la marque et son modèle
économique parce que c'est mon métier
qui l'a pas été fabriqués par des
ouvriers qui ont été payés décemment et
qui travaillent dans de bonnes
conditions dans la résine
si je décompose ce vêtement je peux dire
que le salaire de l'ouvrière qui l'a
fabriqué c'est l'équivalent de ce petit
liseret la 1 2 3 % maximum du prix total
si c'est une bangladaise
elle a gagné 20 centimes de l'heure j'ai
rencontré au bangladesh des ouvrières du
textile qui travaillait six jours sur
sept 14 heures par jour dans des
ateliers non ventilé pour 20 centimes de
l'heure même au bangladesh
ça suffit pas pour vivre décemment alors
on sent coupable
on a un peu raison on se sent démuni en
là faut pas parce que lorsqu'on n'a pas
le choix on a le pouvoir
on a le pouvoir de peser sur ses marques
parce que s'il ya quelques années les
consommateurs le demandez pas trop
rémy de casino avait raison aujourd'hui
c'est faux les consommateurs le demande
il ya une chose qu'ils ont sous-estiment
c'est le talon d'achille de ces grandes
marques leur image parce que lorsque
benetton indemnise les victimes d'un
drame lorsque carrefour signe un accord
dont il ne veut pas lorsqu'elle chem
nous apprend à être des consommateurs
responsables en recyclant des vêtements
qu'on achète chez lui parce que c'est
bon pour la planète
lol eh ben ils ne cèdent pas un accès de
philanthropie il cède alors basic
instinct de survie économique face au
risque de boycott des consommateurs
il ya un slogan qui m'a marqué à mes
débuts dans le milieu des ong
c'était celui du contre sommet du g8
donc ce groupe des huit pays les plus
riches de la planète qui se réunissait
en 2003 et virant c'est un slogan un peu
naïf un peu réducteur un slogan quoi
qu'ils disaient ils sont huit
nous sommes des milliards c'est pas
vraiment nous sommes des milliards à
descendre dans la rue pour manifester
contre des politiques on estime injuste
n'aurait remarqué
mais nous sommes bien des milliards à
avoir nos vies a affecté par les
décisions prises par les pays riches qui
protègent leurs intérêts et ceux leurs
multinationales alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait mais il ya des gens dont c'est le
métier d'être informé de proposer des
alternatives et des solutions et
aujourd'hui on a des moyens pour faire
masse qui n'existaient pas effectivement
il ya un an
alors c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas tous
payer pour sauver le monde mais
aujourd'hui on peut pas ne pas savoir et
savoir sa force à agir
alors je voudrais vous présenter
quelques mesures efficaces et très
simples que vous pouvez faire pour agir
et agir en tant que citoyen il ya
plusieurs étapes la première niveau
débutant sur un peu timide peut partager
l'information
ça paraît anodin mais c'est essentiel
sur facebook ou twitter sur les réseaux
sociaux même par mail les entreprises
sont extrêmement sensibles elle vérifie
quotidiennement la récurrence de leurs
noms sur le net elles adaptent leur
stratégie au bruit des réseaux sociaux
niveau 2 gros challenge un peu plus
impliquant j'en conviens on peut signer
les pétitions et se dire que c'est bien
de signer des pétitions
les pétitions ça fonctionne mais cela
fonctionne pas tout seul ça fonctionne
parce que les alternatives
il ya des revendications et les moyens
de les mettre en oeuvre tout ça c'est le
boulot des ong
en revanche on a besoin d'une chose la
voix des citoyens
votre voix et si vous avez peur d'être
estampillé militants signant des
pétitions
ne vous inquiétez pas on peut être
militant et très fréquentables
les campagnes de tweets ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne très bien vous n'imaginez pas
le poids que vous pouvez avoir sur des
sénateurs ou des députés par exemple
pour mettre un terme à l'impunité des
multinationales il faut en passer par la
loire lorsqu'ils reçoivent en amont de
l'examen d'une loi des centaines de
truites les interpellant alors oui c'est
du lobbying que j'assume entièrement
avec deux différences majeures avec le
lobbing pratiqué par tous les acteurs
économiques d'une paris et transparent
d'autre part il sert l'intérêt l'intérêt
général et ça ça change tout un lobbying
citoyens en fait le seul qui devrait
être autorisé ensuite niveau 3 là c'est
vraiment livré warriors vous pouvez
directement interpellé les marques sur
les réseaux sociaux par mail dans les
boutiques on a vu des batteries de
vendeurs formé chez h&m chez levi's
suite à une campagne que nous avons de
mener pour interdire le sablage dans le
tech comme technique de blanchiment des
jeans
tout ça ça marche mais ça marche pas
facile hein mais ça marche ça marche si
on est nombreux
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de votre
voir cette voix c'est celle de la
reconquête du pouvoir politique par les
citoyens et la donner c'est participer
au monde que l'on souhaite créer parce
qu en fait personne ne veut bouffer des
pesticides
personne ne veut exploiter des enfants
dans les mines à coltan pour avoir un
smartphone
personne ne veut que monsanto les labos
pharmaceutiques dictent les politiques
agricoles ou sanitaire personne ne va
avoir des vêtements tachés de sang et
pour refuser ça vous allez tous ces
outils et surtout il faut pas être
militant il faut pas être engagée même
pas il faut juste être concernés et là
nous sommes très nombreux
merci